hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so very quickly let me
introduce myself producers
i've been working as a professional
trainer for the past six years in hong
kong
and right now i'm doing youtube videos
where i'm mostly talking about technical
analysis which is what i'm using
to build up my scenarios and set up my
trades so in today's video i want to
make an update
on the bitcoin and the dutch coin guys
let's get into it
so which one should i start with let's
start with the dutch con
i know you guys you know have some
passion for
this new coin i mean patient you just
you know
think it's gonna go higher because elon
musk is gonna send it on the moon
that is actually a very valid thinking
and i'm gonna try guys to make some
technical analysis
on this crazy asset and actually you
know the method
that is working the best because i've
been using it on bitcoin i'm going to
show you very soon
on those kind of very volatile assets
is idiot wave principle so what we're
trying to do
is to build up five waves when the price
action is going higher and to build up
three waves abc corrections when the
price action is going lower
so let's do it with the dutch coin all
right so let me remove everything
okay now i want to make my videos a bit
short so i could do it again with you
but just you know accept what i'm
showing you guys all right so we're
gonna start here
one two three and
each time i make a three i need to find
five waves in it one two three four five
this is a valid three and you can see
that for example you can
break down this on the shorter time
frame every time the question i'm having
is
is this move finished so to do that i
need
to find five waves in my fifth waves
so my fifth wave so very important where
you put the start of your fifth wave
but i'm gonna put it here guys so this
is what
i decided to do because
i can see the third wave here so then my
force
must be here and then we're having a one
two here
so then i go on there you know i zoom in
a bit
so i'm having one two here with the two
being a zigzag
you know you can always break down
everything so a
b c working and my third wave
you know i should find five waves here
so let's see if i can do it
so one two
three four five it works
and the third wave so the golden rule
that you must
apply is the third wave cannot be the
shortest the third wave is usually
so it's not a rule it's like usually
happening like this
is uh the most impulsive but sometimes
the fifth is going to be more impulsive
it's fine
and in a correction you usually have a
triangle of flat in the second wave and
usually a triangle on the false wave if
you guys want to know more just click on
the link in the description of this
video and you're going to receive a free
video where i explain everything about
this
theory so here
i can do one two three four five so the
conclusion is already here guys
and to be honest i have a friend maybe
he's watching the video
when he asked me to look at the dutch
coin
at work for the first time immediately i
could see something was missing
you know i could see that you know then
i did my counting properly and i
confirmed that this
impression was actually correct
something is missing because
here we are having a triangle guys so
when you spot a triangle you know this
is the beginning of a triangle but when
you spot one
for example here we had one two guys all
right this was a triangle if i zoom in i
won't do this here
but you guys can do it you zoom in
you're gonna find an ascending triangle
and here yes this is exactly what we're
having all right
so we are i'm telling you right now
maybe i'm wrong
but i give my scenario 75 chance of
being correct
i think we are doing an ascending
triangle so ascending triangles are
developing in five waves a b c d e
it can be seven it can be nine all right
but five waves
is the usual triangle and triangles are
usually in the force wave
and anyway i'm missing fifth wave you
know i tried to do my counting
doing for example it could be three
all right four five it could
but then here you wouldn't have this
kind of stuff you would have
a one two three four five going lower if
this was finished
first thing second thing here i can do
five waves one two three four five
but the third wave is very weak so it
could be like this let's be honest
it could be like this but then i would
need to see a one two three four five
coming here so i would
need to see the price action getting
smashed down and i don't believe this is
gonna happen because the b
wave went very high here i would have
expected something like this
one two three four five then i would
have finished this wave but here what
i'm seeing
what i'm seeing is very different guys
i'm seeing something that is
consolidating with making
higher lows guys so this is a triangle
and triangles like i said are usually in
a force wave so
let's see if this triangle is completing
but i expect
the triangle to last until around the
28th of april
so the resistance level is at 142
you know 143 145 something like this and
the support level
is actually increasing then i expect
a breakout of this triangle on the
upside
something like this and then i expect
the fifth wave
so the question everybody has is where
this fixed wave
is going to go let me answer that so to
do that
to know where the fixed wave is going to
go you guys need to
use fib extensions and to measure the
third wave and to check the different
ratios so where is the third wave here
this is wrong right
okay so you measure the third wave
that's why idiot with counting is very
important guys because if the counting
is correct
then everything else is correct if the
counting is wrong
then everything else is wrong too so i
measure this
and i apply it to the bottom here
and i'm having 0.91 the most likely
extension ratio of fibonacci is 1.618
guys
so i expect the fifth wave to go to 0.91
this is my level let's see if i'm
correct let's see if the strangle
is actually developing the way i told
you guys and
yeah if it goes to 0.91 then we're
probably gonna have a deeper correction
and probably you know an abc correction
and then probably you know
a new one two three four five so guys
that's it for me i hope you enjoyed this
video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys